TUCKER?
>> Tucker: AMAZING TRACE
GALLAGHER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT THE MOTHER YOU
JUST SAW IN THAT VIDEO JOINS
US TONIGHT FROM
PHILADELPHIA.
ASHLEY, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
WHAT -- YOU WERE THERE IN
THE VIDEO WITH THREE GIRLS,
I THINK TWO OF THEM ARE
YOURS.
HOW OLD ARE THEY?
>> SO, MY DAUGHTERS ARE 15
AND 13.
AND MY DAUGHTER'S FRIEND WHO
WAS WITH US IS ALSO 15.
>> Tucker: 15 AND 13.
WHAT DO THEY THINK OF THIS?
>> IT WAS -- IT WAS A
SHOCKING EXPERIENCE.
WHAT IS NOT SEEN IN THAT
VIDEO WAS OUR FIRST
INTERACTION WITH MR. SIMS.
HE APPROACHED US ABOUT 20
MINUTES BEFORE THAT, CAME
IN -- I WOULD SAY CAME IN
HOT AND CAME IN YELLING AT
US.
AND REALLY WAS YELLING VERY
DIRECTLY AT THE GIRLS.
VERY SPECIFICALLY AT THE
GIRLS.
SO, I MOVED MYSELF IN
BETWEEN HIM AND THE GIRLS,
ASKED HIM, YOU KNOW, PLEASE
TALK TO ME.
LET'S HAVE A CONVERSATION.
THE TWO OF US AS TWO ADULTS.
BUT HE CONTINUED TO YELL AT
THE GIRLS.
AND THEN EVENTUALLY HE LEFT
AND ABOUT 10 MINUTES LATER
IS WHEN HE CAME BACK
VIDEOTAPING US.
SO, AFTER OUR FIRST
ALTERCATION WITH HIM YOU
KNOW, I WENT AND TALKED TO
MY GIRLS.
AND TOLD THEM, YOU KNOW, I'M
REALLY SORRY THIS HAPPENED.
I'M REALLY PROUD OF YOU GUYS
FOR BEING HERE.
IT WAS HOLY THURSDAY.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE WANTED
TO DO AS A PRAYERFUL ACT OF
THE SERVICE AS WE PREPARED
FOR THE EASTER -- GOING TO
BEGIN THAT NIGHT WITH HOLY
THURSDAY MASS.
AND I TOLD THEM, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES IT'S HARD TO DO
THE RIGHT THING BUT I WAS
REALLY PROUD OF THEM.
SADLY, IRONICALLY, THE TWO
OLDER GIRLS LOOKED AT ME AND
SAID MOM, THAT WAS NOTHING
COMPARED TO WHAT PEOPLE WERE
SCREAMING AT US AT THE MARCH
FOR LIFE IN JANUARY THEY
WENT TO THE MARCH FOR LIFE
AT THEIR HIGH SCHOOL.
SO, I GUESS I WAS GRATEFUL
THAT THEY HAD HAD SOME
EXPERIENCE BEFORE.
THEY WERE PREPARED FOR IT
AND BECAUSE THEY WERE ABLE
TO KIND OF STAY CALM, THAT
HELPED MY YOUNGER DAUGHTER
STAY CALM.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE PRAYED FOR
HIM THEN.
I SAID WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PRAY FOR HIM.
AND JUST TRY TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
AND SO THEN HE CAME BACK,
AGAIN, VIDEOTAPING US.
WE WEREN'T AS SHOCKED
BECAUSE WE JUST HAD THE
INTERACTION WITH HIM ABOUT
10 MINUTES PRIOR.
SO, YEAH.
BUT IT WAS -- MY ADRENALINE
WAS UP AS A MOM.
MY ADRENALINE WAS RUNNING.
>> Tucker: HE SEEMS TO
THREATEN YOU.
HE OFFERS MONEY FOR YOUR
IDENTITIES.
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: DID YOU FEEL
THREATENED?
>> I WAS CONCERNED FOR MY
GIRLS.
YOU CAN SEE ME SPEAKING IN
THAT VIDEO.
I WAS GENUINELY TRYING TO
ENTER INTO JUST A DIALOGUE
WITH HIM TO TRY TO BRING THE
SITUATION, CALM IT DOWN A
LITTLE BIT.
AND SAY TO HIM ON FILM WE
ARE REALLY HERE JUST PRAYING
FOR THESE WOMEN AND BABIES.
WE ARE NOT LOOKING FOR AN
ALTERCATION.
I NEVER COME TO CLINICS
LOOKING FOR A FIGHT.
IT'S ALWAYS JUST WITH
PEACEFUL, PRAYERFUL INTENT.
YES, I WAS CONCERNED THAT HE
SAID MULTIPLE TIMES THAT HE
WANTED THE IDENTITIES OF MY
DAUGHTERS.
WE WERE AT THAT POINT
ALREADY DONE.
WE HAD FINISHED OUR PRAYERS.
WE WERE LEAVING AND SO WHEN
I REALIZED HE WAS NOT GOING
TO ENTER INTO ANY KIND OF
PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE I
THOUGHT WE WILL JUST
CONTINUE OUR EXIT AND WE
WILL JUST LEAVE.
I NEVER THOUGHT -- I DIDN'T
EVER THINK MORE WOULD REALLY
COME OF IT.
>> Tucker: SO HE ATTACKS YOU
IN THAT VIDEO AND ATTACKS
OTHERS IN THE VIDEO WE
SHOWED BEFORE FOR THEIR SKIN
COLOR.
WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT?
WAS THAT OUT OF NOWHERE?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT
MEANS.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO ASK HIM.
I MEAN, MY DAUGHTERS AND I
ARE CAUCASIAN BUT WE WERE
THERE TO PRAY FOR ALL WOMEN.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T LOOK AT
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN AS
THEY COME OR GO.
MY DAUGHTER'S FRIEND IS NOT
CAUCASIAN.
THAT'S VERY EVIDENT AND HER
VIDEO AND PICTURES.
SHE SAID SEVERAL TIMES TO
HIM OVER THE COURSE OF OUR
INTERACTIONS I'M NOT WHITE,
SIR.
I KNOW IT'S IN THE VIDEO AT
LEAST ONCE.
SO, FORTUNATELY WE KIND OF
GOT A LAUGH OUT OF THAT
BECAUSE WHAT HE WAS SAYING
LITERALLY JUST DIDN'T MAKE
SENSE.
IT DIDN'T MAKE SENSE.
>> Tucker: IT'S A RACIST
ATTACK.
IT'S BIZARRE.
HAS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF
PENNSYLVANIA OR PHILADELPHIA
APOLOGIZED TO YOU?
>> I HAVE NOT BEEN
CONTACTED.
>> Tucker: BY ANYBODY?
>> NO.
I HAVEN'T BEEN CONTACTED BY
ANYONE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ABOUT THIS SITUATION
AT ALL.
>> Tucker: HE CALLED YOU
RACIST.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT YOU ARE
ARGUING FOR FEWER ABORTIONS
AMONG AFRICAN-AMERICAN
WOMEN.
IS HE ARGUING FOR MORE.
BUT YOU ARE THE RACIST?
>> YES.
>> Tucker: DOES THAT MAKE
SENSE?
>> NO.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO ASK
MR. SIMS WHAT HIS LOGIC IS
BEHIND THAT.
>> Tucker: HE WON'T COME ON
TONIGHT.
YOU WERE GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO
COME.